Master Card reports this morning that
holiday retail sales increased 4.9
percent this year according to one
survey 68% of Americans plan to give
tech items as gifts digital voice
assistants like the Amazon echo or
Google home were some of this year's top
sellers and the Nintendo switch video
game console sold more than 10 million
units after this year's launch Dan
Ackerman with our partners at C net is
here with some other hot product stand
great to have you here we saw some of
the products in the green room we did so
we'll talk about the best sellers but
let's first start with the lackluster
headline from Apple their iPhone tens
are not selling the way they were
expected to why now it's really
interesting now I think we might have
hit a natural price ceiling what people
feel comfortable paying for a phone
$1,000 even though previously the
highest end phones if you added the
extra storage space and other
accessories could get up that higher
higher just saying that's the entry
price you know that's kind of a big
barrier for people and I think people
expected this phone to be hard to get
all we did was talk about shortages and
how you're gonna wait till January to
get one they were actually pretty easy
to find but maybe people got scared off
that's just too high that's just too
high so one thing you're a big fan of is
this sonís one it's a high-end speaker
that has alexa built into it everybody
likes the Amazon echo but the speaker
built into it is not great for music
even though it's such a great device for
streaming music from Amazon from Spotify
sonís has a new version of its speaker
called the Sonos one and it has Alexa
built in a lot of other gadgets from
other companies are adding Alexa now so
you don't have to get the Amazon
hardware you can get someone else's
hardware and just have that smart
assistant built in this thing sounds
really good for $200 it's one of the
things people at the CNET offices are
always you know grabbing and needing to
borrow yeah virtual reality headset
something I had a chance to try last
year if you haven't it's absolutely
amazing and now prices are dropping so
what are we seeing with these they are
and that's exactly you really need to
try it and experience it it's almost
like 3d TV you can tell somebody about
it but until you see it that's how
they're gonna sell them by getting
people to see them and by getting in
more people's hands by lowering the
prices you know the main ones like the
oculus rift started it like $600 plus
accessories now it's down to 400 the
PlayStation
Villar they drop the entry price for
that down to $200 this holiday season
and it works with the PlayStation 4
console you probably already have so
really seeing the prices come down it's
been super interesting to see see more
people get into this because it's not a
transformational experience but you
can't see it on TV or on a screen you
have to like try it yeah and all of this
sounds familiar because my husband
should be sitting with you he's a tech
gadget freak as well and he has told me
about this Amazon key which actually
allows Amazon to deliver products unlock
your door and leave it in your home how
does that work yeah we're always worried
about getting products delivered we're
just talk about Amazon lockers at Whole
Foods stores another option Amazon is
starting to offer it's a controversial
one is you have them install a smart
lock and some other hardware and then
they can give delivery people access to
your house to bring the product to bring
your packages in and then leave
obviously a lot of people are
uncomfortable with this concept but it's
an interesting way to extend that smart
home experience from just having let's
say a smart lock or smart camera and
actually bringing the store into the
process all right Dan you and I and
almost all Americans are video game
nerds let's talk about the Nintendo
switch a very hot product this year as
well as pressure cookers didn't get the
switch it is one of the fastest selling
consoles in Nintendo history it is it is
I also got an instant pot for my video
games you know the switch really really
surprised me pleasantly it sounded very
overly complex at first that tablet you
could play games on that you could plug
into a dock connect to your TV little
controllers that pop off from the sides
but it's that rare combination of
hardware and software that really worked
well together and I think that people
loved it because it brought back that
family style played together in the same
room that shared experience because you
can split the screen and play like a
racing game together with your family
members I play with my son all the time
he plays with his friends so I think
it's that social utility more than the
actual you know games and the hardware
and the tech stuff that really made this
a hit videogames bringing people
together they either make the stuff
where they sell the stuff where they
deliver the stuff or the world they're
selling you your groceries that's
exactly
thank you thank you